elles sont vos des amis depuis l'âge de
5 ans aujourd'hui au lycée à l'école
sainte hélène différentes ressemblante
elles savent tout sur l'une et l'autre
elle n'oublie jamais une amitié qui va
se fragiliser écrit par evan placés en
hauteur canadien ses fils à est inspiré
de l'histoire d'amanda todd
la jeune canadienne a posté une vidéo
juste avant de se suicider en 2012
histoire de harcèlement ça raconte
surtout comment on arrive à l'intérieur
d'un groupe à se faire exister que non
et quels sont les rapports que peuvent
avoir les individus d'aujourd'hui avec
les collectifs avec les groupes et
comment de ton temps c'est compliqué de
tenir sa propre parole d'être ce qu'on a
envie d'être sur scène ils tous
comédienne professionnelle et huit
amateurs l'icem étudiants issus de la sq
rabal théâtre elles ont travaillé leur
rôle pendant deux semaines avant de
monter sur la scène de la ferme de bel
ébat peut-être trop sensible mais des
fois quand il ya des scènes
particulièrement émouvante
j'étais au bord des larmes je me sentais
trop triste et donc du coup voilà tu as
plus les comédiens confessionnelles il
était très gentil avec nous mais j'étais
franchement adorable du coup voilà ça a
contribué à rendre l'expérience est
inoubliable
les comédiennes professionnelles avaient
une précision et une intensité de jeu
assez assez forte et du coup parce nous
élever un peu dans notre façon de jouer
ces filles là est une pièce porté sur la
volonté de les changes une exploration
de la jeunesse de l'impact des mots de
l'identité on se sent forcément
concernés
vraiment je suis content d'avoir
accompagné mon fils pour regarder la
pièce quoi ce truc c'était très fort
d'un point de vue émotion que c'était
très contemporain parce que voilà c'est
une histoire vraie c'est intéressant
parce que on peut lire beaucoup
d'articles ou voir des films en rapport
avec ça et du coup ci ça y est me au
théâtre ça apporte un autre point de vue
en tournée depuis 2010 est la pièce aux
les passagers les paroles crues elle
décrit des situations difficiles pour
mieux réfléchir et agir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]